the story is that every man who is
supposed to fight for his own survival
many times they're knocking down you get
up a fight and never ever stop
the certainly parts that I can identify
with
season 1 of Spartacus is finished and I
was in a lot of a lot of pain at the end
of that I wasn't sure what it wasn't
wasn't going away I got a call saying
hon I'm in trouble I think I've got
cancer
and they said you know if you do nothing
you'll be dead within through six months
this is huge and terrifying I want for
us now is to be really clear about what
we want from this journey and that is to
just learn from each other grow from it
and not be frightened by we're all in it
together and getting through it as a
family in my heart I am convinced that
this is all meant to be and I'm open to
the adventure of all of this
I feel fine and I look really well it's
gonna be the end of it
doesn't matter
if we are successful or not it's about
the journey but one shin and if you
commit to it something extraordinary
will come of it
that was
be here now it's all about being present
and not fearing what you don't know and
so I feel really inspired to do this
even though I have no idea how it's
going
you